i understand you have a summer class
coming up and it is open to non-ucla
students yes i teach every summer what
we call here summer session a at ucla
which runs for six weeks
starting uh it's actually six my own
class is six monday afternoons
um starting on june 23rd we're recording
this in 2015.
um
and it meets every monday afternoon for
six mondays and it's a rare opportunity
for
to get eight to actually take a seminar
course it's not a lecture course it's a
hands-on writing course with a member of
the senior faculty
in the film school at ucla which is a
very competitive
uh arena and difficult to get into
um you can actually without being a ucla
student you can take this class it's
eight credits you can earn eight
university california credits if you're
a student at another institution you you
might be able to transfer those those
credits
um
it the the class is uh
designed especially for the summer
session to be appropriate for writers
who are
relatively new at writing and also for
writers who are more experienced
it's a
as i say it's a hands-on writing class
that consists
mainly of examining in-progress scripts
collectively all around the room
with everybody commenting
on and then the instructor commenting on
the script but also on the comments
uh so that
there's a lot of interaction
a lot of participation by uh by the
students in the class it's not a passive
experience where you're just sitting in
and listening to the uh the professor
uh and uh i've been offering that class
for over 30 years
to good and grand effect um
and it generally sells out
i don't get paid per student or anything
like that i'm not trying to sell anybody
anything
but it is a an opportunity that i don't
think everybody's aware of to actually
take a film course at ucla
for credit
uh at an advanced level in the in the
film school where it's where you're not
merely being lectured to but you're
having an interactive experience
prerequisites for all prerequisites are
waived it's it's called advanced
screenwriting the the course is ftv
which stands for film television
um 135 a 135a that's just the catalog
number i believe that the actual title
excuse me the title of the course is
advanced screenwriting seminars advanced
screen running workshop something like
that
but if you go to um
the uh
the ucla website and poke around for
summer session
you can uh you know just google ucla
the page will come up
uh which is the main page and there will
be a for the university there'll be a
window in there asking you what you're
looking for and if you poke around in
there you can you can you know you can
put in summer session and maybe find it
that way or maybe you could even provide
a link that would take you to it i would
also say if you go to my website
richardwalter.com there's no s at the
end of my name
richardwalter.com there will be a link
there
that you can click on that will take you
to the um uh
enrollment page so that you can actually
uh register for the class right yeah we
will provide a link at the bottom of
this uh youtube video gonna be great